this
is the way really get the sense that
this is how john favreau responds to
anyone that dares to suggest that these
previous leon segments go on for way too
long
your bravery will not be forgotten give
me a [ __ ] break mando charged the
stormtroopers sure but as we'll see soon
his best car armor can repel a flippin
lightsaber
so is it really that impressive that he
wandered into puny blaster fire to throw
those bombs a few episodes ago
is the giant bell necessary this town is
one street and a few houses
basically the size of bucks north
tennessee i think someone could really
just
shout out from the gate that someone's
coming and everyone would hear at what
point do you realize this blaster fire
is useless on someone with shiny dildos
that deflect them and why wouldn't they
try to flank her considering the frontal
assault clearly isn't working
you know i never understood why
experienced jedi don't do this force
manipulation more often it would be much
easier to take out several enemies by
filling a bunch of dead trees or
something right
seems like this lightsaber show is
honestly just showing off also
tree murder and you might say it was
already dead in which case i will pivot
to overkill
i've lost visual scan for movement you
know this is really something you should
have been doing from the start
considering your field of vision is
severely limited because of your poor
goggle choices and terrible aim
show yourself jedi why did ahsoka wait
until now to attack the village
the magistrate has been in power for a
presumably long time given the state of
the townsfolk in the environment did she
have to wait until almost
everyone was dead or suffering before
she moved on this i've been expecting
you
oh so this is why no one is shooting at
her right now because they need to talk
in which case why send out a team to
kill her in the first place let her
waltz to the wall and wax poetic about
whatever
the lives of these citizens mean nothing
to me then why are
any of them still alive what's the point
of this entire outpost if they're not
doing anything other than torturing
villagers and pruning hedges
also how is there a conversation even
happening right now when everyone is
extremely far apart and surrounded by
airborne detritus and dense fog
everyone should be yelling
surrender or face the consequences you
have one day
to decide the [ __ ] is one day gonna do
to change anything
does ahsoka really think the magistrate
will have a change of heart after
sleeping on this
well if anything she's got the advantage
right now charge
amanda eventually gets pissed that baby
odds yanks his ball but why
he willingly gave it to the kid to play
with back in the first season and it
doesn't look like it's essential for the
whatchamacallit to do the thing of my
doodle
also why is he just now noticing the
ball on the lever when he's been sitting
up front for this entire journey from
navarro to corvus
also also ball shadowing amanda flew
right over the town just a few seconds
ago so why do you park all the way out
here in the boonies
especially when the first thing they do
is look for the town
this needs to stay in the ship so
obviously i'll put it in my pocket
rather than walk the 30 feet back to the
ship and put it where it belongs
not much to see out here decorvus
station turtlenecks
i find it hard to believe given what we
know about the child's appetite that he
wouldn't be jumping out of that bag and
scarfing down everything on the street
like the samples at costco
pardon me vendor he just called that
woman
vender who refers to a person by their
occupation especially if they're a
vendor that would be like someone coming
up to me and saying pardon me youtuber
and podcaster what night lives in that
castle
what's the point of these double sealed
doors when the wall is barely eight feet
tall and easily scalable
okay the guards are there but if they're
taken out this place is easy peasy to
overtake so easy that even i could do it
i mean i can't right now because i'm
waiting for my pot pie to cool and then
i have to take the crust off and
then i separate it out and eat the
turkey first but you know later maybe
you are a mandalorian i mean what gave
it away
pure best car i've played enough video
games to know the tells of a boss fight
in this case it's the loot drop
containing a weapon that perfectly
matches your armor
dead giveaway and total [ __ ] but you
don't care because matching set
also how does this lady just happen to
have a spear made out of one of the
rarest metals in the galaxy
she might as well have a bunch of
vibranium in her basement also also why
does the magistrate think this is a fair
payment for offing a freaking jedi
i know mandalorians are big on best
guard but he's got it all over his body
and this thing is really just a really
strong pointy object
it doesn't even pupe you well these are
the coordinates
the magistrate gave him exact
coordinates if they know where ahsoka is
this precisely how haven't they mounted
an attack on her before now
i know she's a dope-ass jedi but they
could strike while she's asleep or
something
wow the scope has a built-in zoom and
enhanced cliche that can be activated by
the click of a button
okay why does ahsoka attack mando
immediately maybe because mandalorians
and jedi have been enemies for a long
time okay but she's friendly with bo
katan who's also a mandalorian so what
gives with that
and she must sense the presence of the
child given how powerful she is with the
force so why didn't she ask
any questions before trying to carve the
poor bastard up boca tan sent me
you know her right middle name ra loves
warm weather wearing linen shorts
shuffleboard
some people will spend the next two
minutes of this episode excitedly
waiting for all of our green bean
questions to be answered i however will
ponder this bruce almighty moon and
worry about anyone living on this planet
for much longer
[Music]
yes grogu grogu come
on his name might as well be carl grow
goo can he still wield the force did
that not come up during your psychic
conversation
the jedi order fell a long time ago well
sure but you
are aware that a jedi and his friends
destroyed two death stars after that
right
and luke is presumably training new kids
as you guys speak seriously how does
ahsoka not know
anything about what's going on with her
brethren these days don't they send out
some sort of newsletter via force
frequencies across the galaxy every few
months
check your spam folder passing stones i
want to see if they'll listen to you
that would be a first oh shut up mando
the kid obeyed earlier went to his car
seat without rolling his eyes or
anything
also i've never seen a jedi training
session that's so unbelievably boring
even rey's obstacle course from rise of
the skywalker was more entertaining
i cannot train him obvious candidate to
train a recruit with special abilities
refuses to train that recruit cliche
and i'll help you with your problem if
you see to it that grogu
is properly trained found the side quest
phew i was worried there for a second
a mandalorian and a jedi they'll never
see it coming
well sure until you start attacking them
really what's the benefit of the
surprise collaboration after you enter
the city gates
why bother having this super secure
entrance if you're just gonna nakedly
walk out here at the first sign of
trouble
even winston hid behind his john wick
three while the real fighters did the
real fighting
okay this is some awesome kirosawa
imagery and i appreciate that this
episode wears its influences directly on
the sleeves of its best car armor rather
than obliquely nodding to them
once in off
your bouncy hunter failed if that were
the case wouldn't she have brought a
part of the armor that was a little more
impressive maybe like the helmet
or even a cod piece deus ex mandalorica
i'm confused is ahsoka a powerful jedi
or just
batman on a different planet don't get
me wrong this fight is rad as hell but
even if the magistrate is a trained
fighter from the clone wars how's she
standing any chance against a super
powerful jedi in a [ __ ] sword fight
who do you think's gonna win it could be
your side
could be my side i mean the dialogue
here is
riveting you guys could be that either
side
could win possibly you and i were a lot
alike
for instance we both like watching
rom-coms and playing candy crush in
addition to ruthlessly killing people
want to get brunch sometime
geez what a dill hole not only should he
know he'd be too slow for mando's draw
what does he think one blaster shot
would do to him does he not see all that
best car
where is grand admiral thrawn and pause
for fanboy applause
no i'm not applauding because i could
give a flip all about rebels or clone
wars or some canon comic that was
written in 1983 by george lucas's 12
year old second cousin i'm watching the
freaking mandalorian man
i don't want to do homework to be able
to follow along may the force be with
you is it just me or was ahsoka super
not helpful in this episode and she gave
the kid the name which i guess is fine
but it's also
[ __ ] grogo she attacked mando used
him to get into the village and take
what she wanted from the magistrate then
sent him on yet another sidequest to
figure out baby yo
grogu's purpose she's as useless as a
green milk producing mammary on a male
thales iron
i happen to pick up another juicy little
nugget
i uh got the first name do the
cinemasins guys secretly love movies
shh have they had a podcast devoted to
discussing movies called scentcast since
2015
have they had a vast array of movie
talks deep dives games guest interviews
q a and much more on the sim cast damn
it i said keep it down
screw it the secrets out check out the
scene cast every monday and more
wherever you do your podcast we have fun
for your lives
everyone
hello hello who is
it it is king arthur whose castle is
this
this is the castle of my master sweden
help us help me
i have a proposition that may interest
you
suppose i were to offer you one million
dollars
you you want the moon just say the word
and i'll throw a lasso around and pull
it down
[Music]
execute them bogus
we'll handle this
[Music]
[Applause]
why johnny ringo
you look like somebody just walked over
your grave
i didn't finish the job no
but sometimes in the heat of the moment
it's forgivable to go ask to mouth i
shall not forget you
how brave you are to be alone in the
woods